how much of this stuff like how much of
it changes because
literally you're becoming wiser how much
of it changes because you don't have
another choice like to let go of that
you know uh uh
midlife crisis when some go through it's
like well i'm not 32 anymore you know
i'm not 38 anymore i'm not you know
whatever that number may be for some
people
uh uh you see it a lot
i think like i remember being 28 years
old i meet this guy he says uh
you know 28 is one the toughest age a
man will go through i said tell me why
28. he says because you're
close to 30 friends are married with
kids you're no longer close to 20.
you're about to hit that number if
you're not married you're going to be
worried if your career is not said you
have all these types of anxiety you may
make some stupid mistakes at 28. and
then you turn 38 and you're wondering if
there's this thing when the number
switches every single time like you go
from 39 to 40 from 49 to 50. did you
ever have something like that with you
or you're like yeah it's just 40 it's
just dirty you're just fishing no my
biggest fear was um regret and i was
afraid i think one of the most important
things are two
of the most important decisions i think
you make in your life one is
who you choose to spend your life with
right so if you're gonna if you're gonna
get married or you're going to
bring somebody in your life that's a
very that decision should be treated
with great gravity and and
and i think if in a lot of times you
don't get lucky with that it's a tough
it's a tough thing but i think the other
thing is to know to learn at a young age
and be ruthless with yourself
where are you supposed to place your
energy and i knew that if i didn't
become a comic or an actor i was gonna i
was gonna become a small person who
didn't like himself how old were you
when you knew that
i
i was
20 i was probably 21
well i went to college and i said i'm
gonna try to be an actor and then i i
talked myself out of it i did some
acting and i said oh well this is very
difficult and i don't know what this
means and there's no linear progression
right i've always liked linear stuff
like if you show me how to get a black
belt or you show me how to learn how to
play the guitar if you show me the way
i'm going to do it and i'll and i'll
figure out a way to get better at it
because it's linear you just go straight
put your head down and just go yeah i've
i've always kind of thrived in routine
and practice i don't have a problem with
that when you have something like acting
or stand up and you know vinnie it's
like there's no path man you've got to
just continue to be you're in the
business of what i call original
self-expression
but for me i knew that once i made the
decision to become an actor and a comic
that i was going to be okay because even
if it didn't work out i had the courage
to go for it and i think you die a
little bit
when you you knew the answer i think you
always know the answer you know it's
like this expression it takes five
minutes to fall in love and the rest is
denial and then there's another
expression which is people get divorced
after 20 years over what they knew about
that person in the first 10 minutes
and i think it's a very important thing
to keep in mind because you know that
about yourself you know people ask
questions me questions as i get older
and stuff you know they want the young
men who want questions about life mostly
you know the answer man usually i go
take take a second do you know the
answer to this question you're just
asking me for affirmation right and i
and i understand that we all do it
because it's scary it's very scary
to
to actually take a minute
and visualize your best self
the you're the hero of your movie
there's a coward of your movie and
there's a hero of your movie and then
there's the guy who's just
kind of going through his life and when
the gunslinger comes to town he closes
the shutters because he's afraid
we have all of that in us man
but to really look at the best version
of yourself the version of yourself that
you would admire that you would go to a
movie to watch the version of yourself
that does the right thing no matter what
that tells the truth and aligns himself
with the highest
truth or good that he can imagine or she
can imagine very scary because it
requires it takes responsibility man it
it
and i don't think anybody can get you
there you have to stand on your own two
feet
and
sometimes it takes a crisis to force you
there you know um but i think it's worth
i really think it's worth meditating on
i think that's that's that's the
that's the north star all of us should
be kind of reaching for and and i don't
mean
just money and status and power i don't
mean just that i don't think that's
enough i really don't
i i think
it's something else and i do think brian
it's and and off of what you were saying
lying to yourself because you once
you're true to you like you said like
when you ask that dude you know you know
you know what you're talking about you
know and i tell people this all the time
i'm not saying be a liar [ __ ] people
[ __ ] you know little white lies that
protect people's feelings don't lie to
you
why are you lying to yourself you know
you're being full of [ __ ] yeah once
you're honest and you don't give a [ __ ]
about anybody's concerns or i mean it's
not easier said than done when you just
don't care and you're just being honest
then you could you know live your life
do you know what i like about this
podcast i watch this podcast i don't
watch very very few things uh and one
thing i notice about you it's gonna
sound really weird but um you listen
very intently and and i've i've heard
you and i've watched you listen i've
watched you interview pretty formidable
people too some mafia guys or just some
very successful people
what i what i
what i liked about you and i didn't know
you but what i liked about you was that
you are genuinely interested
you're curious that has nothing to do
with money it has nothing to do with
anything else it's you're a driven guy
and you're successful but
that's kind of what i'm talking about
you know there's this
there's this i think it's important to
kind of reach beyond yourself
think about how much of our culture
reflects directly back to ourself open a
magazine it's all about nutrition
exercise it's all about your biology all
right dude i got it your hair i mean
there are ways to do it but
that's not necessarily the answer
there are things that part of this whole
process of talking and podcasting what's
great is that man it feeds your
curiosity it satiates your curiosity the
world is okay
so many too many things in life are a
dark room and sometimes you get a
flashlight and you can look around and
yeah so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]